so i've really avoided making a morning
routine video specifically because i
feel like there's just so many of them
on youtube and i feel like morning
routines are generally overrated you
know everyone's seen thumbnails on
youtube of like
the one morning routine that will change
your life actually that sounds like
something that i would make
elon musk morning routine revealed the
secret morning routine of every
billionaire who ever lived apparently
they all did this one morning routine
and it's the reason they're successful
but at the same time though
there's a reason i'm making this video
and it's because if there's one thing
that my life has been lacking
in the past year or so it's been
structure
i feel like a lot of people have felt
the same way it's kind of a meme that
people don't really know what day it is
half the time
and i think people are starting to
realize that it feels good to have to be
somewhere
you know to have responsibilities to
have appointments and meetings it makes
you feel more human
so if our life circumstances has
presented a situation where there's a
way less structure
i think it's important that we invite
more structure and more responsibility
into our life
voluntarily one of the main ways that i
started to do that in my life was by
actually adding a morning routine having
a game plan every time i wake up
and having a sequence of events that i
partake in
that both make me feel like i'm starting
the day on the right foot
and that i'm kind of contributing to
society and moving my life forward so
this video is kind of going over what i
do and hopefully it'll give you some
ideas as to what you can start doing
to add more structure into your life and
gain momentum you know get the ball
moving again
so every morning i wake up at 9 00 a.m
and right off the bat
that's not that early but i'm a huge
night owl
if left to my own devices i'll fall
asleep around 3am
every single night so after i wake up
the most important thing i do
or not do is i don't look at my phone i
don't go on social media i won't go on
reddit i won't go on facebook i won't go
on instagram
i grab my gray hoodie off the little
closet door in my room
and i march downstairs and after i walk
downstairs i'll walk into the kitchen
where i'll start boiling the water for
coffee and while that's heating up i'll
down a large glass of cold water
allegedly this
gets your metabolism going or something
which doesn't really make sense to me
because there's no calories in water
but at the very least it kind of wakes
you up you know a cold glass of water in
the morning will wake you up maybe
because it like makes your brain cold or
something
anyways also down a athletic greens
shake
they're not sponsoring this video or
anything that's just the brand i'm using
right now i might switch to another one
you never know
and i also have two drops of this
vitamin d
complex and i use the green shake to
wash down
my medicinal mushroom blend of lion's
mane
rishi and cordyceps i think that's how
you pronounce it i don't really know if
any of this does anything but i'm a
lifelong sucker for pretending that it
does so after the water's done boiling
i'll use an
arrow press to squeeze out a nice juicy
cup of coffee i think aeropress makes
really great coffee
even better than pour over and i know
i'm triggering like everybody
from portland sometimes if i'm feeling
really fancy i'll add a tablespoon of
mct oil and i will blend it so i got
this nice blended
mct oily coffee allegedly this kind of
bulletproof coffee
increases gray matter in the brain or
something i don't even know if that's
true
but i find that the most useful part of
making coffee like this
is that it helps stave off hunger and
hunger is extremely distracting
when i'm writing so when all that's done
i walk into my office i sit down on my
chair
i light a candle i put my hood up i set
a timer for one hour
and i write and like a monk praying at
the chapel at dawn
writing for one hour every single
morning is something that i'm
starting to take almost religiously
seriously
so the whole idea around this odd
sequence of events
is that it's all surrounding a central
activity it's an almost
sacred ritualistic act that prepares the
way for the main
event which is writing and there's a
reason why i've chosen
writing as the central activity instead
of you know editing or
shooting b-roll or responding to emails
it's because i've identified writing as
the backbone of my
entire career without me putting pen to
paper
or finger to keyboard i will have
nothing to talk about in front of the
camera which means i'll have nothing to
edit
and nothing to upload and when i have a
script or a set of ideas that i think is
really tight and that i'm really
proud of i'm infinitely more excited to
talk about it and share my thoughts in
front of the camera and if i think what
i'm sharing in front of the camera is
super tight and well thought out then
i'm infinitely more likely to not
procrastinate the living out of
editing it even shooting the b-roll is
way more fun when i know the overall
product is something that i'm really
proud of so the overall fulfillment of
my life
and what i do on a day-to-day basis
rides pretty heavily
on me doing a good job of the writing
unfortunately though
writing is also something i hate doing
ever since i started this channel
writing has been the thorn in my side
it's the thing that i procrastinate the
most
by far mostly because compared to
being all cinematic and artsy with my
b-roll and editing funny memes into my
edit
editing editing funny memes into my
editing writing is super
like excruciatingly mundane in
comparison
you're just sitting there hitting your
fingers against plastic
trying to siphon out some kind of gold
but it's usually coal that's the
narrative i have in my head anyways
and it's this narrative of writing being
dreadful
that adds a lot of fuel to this feeling
of resistance the resistance that stops
me from just
sitting down and working and the longer
i put it off the more the resistance
grows in power
and before i made writing the first
thing that i do
every single morning i'd postpone
writing for as long as possible for
hours and hours
days and days i would do every single
other thing other than just
sitting down and writing but the
hilarious thing is it's actually not
that hilarious
it's just sad the resistance i feel
towards writing
is a lot more unpleasant than the
writing itself
once i start writing it's actually quite
pleasant and
peaceful and dare i say i actually
really enjoy it you know it's kind of
sucky at first maybe for the first five
or ten minutes
but very soon after i've settled down my
brain has slowed down
and i get into the flow every single
time it's like clockwork which has
really made me realize
that a lot of the time the resistance
that we feel towards doing
the most important thing that we have to
do in a day is
more unpleasant than just doing the
thing itself and if we eventually have
to do the thing itself
after a long enough timeline then why
add all of this suffering in between
before we just engage with the suffering
of action
it's like suffering twice why suffer
twice when you can just suffer once and
when you structure your day like this
you know you wake up you do these fancy
things to set the stage for this
important thing that you have to do and
you get in the habit of actually doing
this thing every single morning
there's a certain level of existential
security that you'll start to feel you
know you don't have this dark cloud
looming over your head all the time you
will live most of the day as somebody
who has done that thing already
rather than someone who has to do that
thing you know maybe you're working a
job that you don't really like
and you have this side hustle that you
keep on fantasizing about as your way
out schedule
one hour to work on it every single
morning non-negotiable or maybe you're
enjoying your career and you have to
show up to work in a
brick and mortar building but usually
you have tasks to do and you should do
the most important task
first doing the most important thing
that you have to do
every single morning getting that fat
ass monkey off your back and
throwing it to the side or killing it
but it's kind of an immortal monkey
because you kill it one day and it'll
show up the next day but if you get in
the habit of doing that you'll start to
walk around life with the exaggerated
swagger of a
monkey killing psychopath you'll just
feel so good
you'll free up so much time later in the
day to learn new things
and there's no better way to learn new
things than by using today's video
sponsor
skillshare for those of you who don't
know skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of classes covering dozens of topics
everything from creative writing to
photography to how to cook like a chef
and how to edit like a professional
editor no matter what you're into or
what you want to learn
skillshare probably has a class for it
and chances are it's also extremely
practical
because every single class on skillshare
is designed for real life
it's so easy to take whatever you're
learning on skillshare and apply it to
your real-life pursuits which is exactly
why
i'm taking yet another photography class
on skillshare
i have my fujifilm camera and i really
want to take it out more
and work on my composition and the
classes on skillshare are often
really inspiring there are so many
talented instructors on there and they
really get me
just craving the outdoors and wanting to
shoot everything that moves
with a camera skillshare is also
extremely affordable with the annual
membership it comes in at less than ten
dollars a month
so it's kind of a no-brainer and the
first 1000 of you who click
the link in the description below will
get a free trial of a skillshare premium
membership so use the link down below
dive into your first class on skillshare
learn something new
explore your creativity and as usual
have a great time
if you like this video make sure you hit
like because when you hit like
the algorithm blesses me and it shoves
my bald head into other people's home
pages helping them out
and it also helps me out and if they're
gonna get a notification on their phone
it might as well be about
content telling them to not spend so
much time on their phone
and if you watch better ideas regularly
and you say to yourself this is kind of
a cool channel joey seems like a cool
guy
why don't you subscribe to my second
channel you know check that out i've
been posting there every single week
i have a show called joey answers your
questions the show it's extremely me
it's a lot more laid back
but i'm personally having a great time
with the videos and you guys seem to be
having a great time too
we also have a better idea subreddit you
guys are posting tons of memes there
and i will react to them on the second
channel and i have been reacting to them
on the second channel the links for
those are in the description or probably
on this video somewhere
other than that thanks so much for
watching and we'll catch you in the next
video
you